Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you to take a moment to fill out our listener survey. We want to learn more about you, what you think of this podcast, and what topics you'd like us to cover. So after you listen to this episode, please go to our website, www.spinkingofpsychology.org, and look for the link to our listener survey. There will also be a link in the show notes for this episode. Thanks in advance for taking our little poll, and now on to the episode. In February, the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention released data showing that teen girls in the U.S. are engulfed in what they called a wave of sadness and violence. The numbers are startling.
在今天开始之前，我想请大家花点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们想更多地了解您，了解您对本播客的看法，以及您希望我们涵盖哪些主题。因此，在收听完本期节目后，请访问我们的网站 www.spinkingofpsychology.org，并查找听众调查问卷的链接。本期节目的节目说明中也会提供链接。提前感谢您参与我们的小调查，现在让我们进入正题。二月份，美国疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）发布的数据显示，美国少女正陷入他们所称的“悲伤与暴力浪潮”之中。这些数字令人震惊。
Nearly one in three teen girls has seriously considered suicide. 57% of teen girls said they felt persistently sad or hopeless. And 18% had experienced sexual violence in the prior year. The report also found extremely high levels of distress among LGBTQ plus teens. More than one in five of them had attempted suicide in the prior year, and more than half reported poor mental health. Today we're going to dig into those numbers. What is behind this crisis in teen mental health?
近三分之一的少女曾认真考虑过自杀。57%的少女表示她们感到持续的悲伤或绝望。18%的少女在过去一年中经历过性暴力。报告还发现，LGBTQ+青少年的痛苦程度极高。超过五分之一的受访者在过去一年中曾尝试自杀，超过半数的人报告心理健康状况不佳。今天，我们将深入探讨这些数字。青少年心理健康危机的背后是什么？
Are we just seeing the effects of the pandemic? Is it social media? Something else? Why are girls suffering so much more than boys? Which teens are more at risk? And what can parents, peers, schools, and communities do to help teens cope and stay safe and healthy in the face of such widespread distress? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
我们看到的仅仅是疫情的影响吗？是社交媒体吗？还是其他原因？为什么女孩比男孩承受的痛苦多得多？哪些青少年面临的风险更高？面对如此广泛的痛苦，家长、同龄人、学校和社区能做些什么来帮助青少年应对并保持安全与健康？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Kathleen Ethier, director of the CDC's Division of Adolescent and School Health, which put out the new report. She has been at the CDC for more than 20 years, leading research and policy work on health issues affecting youth and women. Before joining the CDC, she spent six years on the research faculty at Yale University, working on studies of HIV, STDs, and unplanned pregnancy prevention. Dr. ETHier holds a PhD in Social Psychology from the Graduate Center of the City University of New York. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. ETHier. Hi, so glad to be here. Let's start with the numbers I mentioned in the introduction. Almost one-third of teen girls said they have considered suicide, almost three and five, felt persistently said, and hopeless, and 18% had experienced sexual violence.
我今天的嘉宾是CDC青少年与学校健康部门的主任凯瑟琳·埃西尔（Kathleen Ethier）博士，该部门发布了这份新报告。她在CDC工作了20多年，领导有关影响青少年和女性健康问题的研究与政策工作。在加入CDC之前，她在耶鲁大学研究学院工作了六年，从事艾滋病、性传播疾病和意外怀孕预防方面的研究。埃西尔博士拥有纽约市立大学研究生中心社会心理学博士学位。感谢您今天参加我的节目，埃西尔博士。嗨，很高兴来到这里。让我们从我在介绍中提到的数字开始。近三分之一的少女表示她们曾考虑过自杀，近五分之三的人感到持续的悲伤和绝望，18%的人经历过性暴力。
I think most members of the public who have heard these numbers were alarmed. And as someone who's been working in the field for a long time, what about you? Were you surprised? Were you alarmed? Yeah, obviously, yes. we you know the euthress behavior survey which is the data that um which the report that we released is is part not all but part of the data um that's contained in the uterus behavior survey you know the survey has been around for more than 30 years um and as an adolescent health
我想大多数听到这些数字的公众都会感到震惊。作为一名在该领域工作了很长时间的人，您呢？您感到惊讶吗？您感到震惊吗？是的，显然，是的。我们知道“青少年风险行为调查”（YRBS）是我们发布报告的数据来源，虽然不是全部，但它是该调查所包含数据的一部分。你知道，这项调查已经进行了30多年，作为一名青少年健康专家……
um my background is in adolescent health i've been studying adolescent health for many many years and so we use the wirebS all the time it's pretty standard or pretty standard way of understanding the health and well-being of young people in the country. And so I think, you know, we had been seeing prior to the pandemic, we'd been seeing mental health move in the wrong direction. We had seen that kind of centered around female students and LGBTQ plus students. And then during the pandemic, we had additional confirmation that youth mental health was in crisis, that teenage girls seemed to be at higher risk.
我的背景是青少年健康，我研究青少年健康已经很多很多年了，所以我们一直都在使用YRBS。这是了解全国年轻人健康和福祉的一种非常标准的方式。所以我认为，你知道，在疫情之前，我们就已经看到心理健康在朝着错误的方向发展。我们看到这种趋势集中在女学生和LGBTQ+学生身上。然后在疫情期间，我们得到了进一步的证实，即青少年心理健康正处于危机之中，少女似乎处于更高的风险中。
So we saw some data from emergency room visits indicating that they were more likely to be showing up during the pandemic with having attempted suicides. We had some inklings. I think we were not, we weren't prepared, I would say, for the consistency across all of the different measures that we included in the report. And then also some of the 10-year trends that we've been monitoring for, you know, kind of the past number of years. And so, you know, we include these individual measures in this report around sexual behavior, substance use, experience of violence and mental health and suicide. Because for us in the Division of Adolescent School, help it speaks to the programmatic work. We know that these factors are interconnected. Most of these variables, we've included, this is the third time we've done this particular report.
我们看到一些急诊室就诊数据表明，在疫情期间，她们因尝试自杀而就诊的可能性更高。我们有一些预感。我想说，对于报告中包含的所有不同指标的一致性，我们并没有做好准备。还有我们监测了十年的某些趋势。所以，你知道，我们在报告中包含了关于性行为、物质使用、暴力经历以及心理健康和自杀的个体指标。因为对于我们青少年与学校健康部门来说，这关系到项目工作。我们知道这些因素是相互关联的。我们纳入了大多数变量，这是我们第三次制作这份特定的报告。
We include them every single time. We have some shifts to make sure we're being relevant. And so we didn't look at the data really before we decided to have that these were the set of variables we were going to include in this report. So when we put it all together and looked at the data and looked kind of across, we were not expecting that for all of the substance use measures that we include in the report. And it's not every substance use measure that's in the wire BS, but for the measures that we included in this report, for almost all of the experiences of violence except for, being threatened or injured with a weapon, and across all of the mental health and suicidal thoughts and behavior data we included in this report, that girls would be so significantly at such a significant increase compared to boys. And that was just really consistent,
我们每次都包含这些变量。我们做了一些调整以确保其相关性。因此，在决定将这些变量集纳入本报告之前，我们并没有真正查看数据。所以当我们把所有数据放在一起观察时，我们并没有预料到，在报告中包含的所有物质使用指标中——虽然不是YRBS中的每一个物质使用指标，但在我们纳入本报告的指标中，以及除了“受到武器威胁或伤害”之外的所有暴力经历，还有我们报告中包含的所有心理健康和自杀念头及行为数据中，女孩的比例会比男孩高出这么多。这真的非常一致，
and I think we were not expecting that. You know, we've been monitoring kind of in these 10-year chunks some of these variables like the proportion of youth who had been forced to have sex. And so when we, in 2017, when we looked at that 10-year trend in 2019, when we looked at that 10-year trend, there were no changes over those 10-year periods in that variable. When we looked at the 2011 to 2021 data, that was the first time we'd really seen an increase in that measure, that trend measure. And so that was really also very alarming to us. you know, we've been saying for a while that, that, you know, out of every 10 teenage girls that you know, at least one has been raped. And that has been consistent for the number of years that we've been looking at these 10-year trends.
我想我们没有预料到这一点。你知道，我们以十年为周期监测了其中一些变量，比如被迫发生性行为的青少年比例。所以当我们在2017年观察2019年的十年趋势时，该变量在这些十年期间没有变化。当我们观察2011年到2021年的数据时，那是我们第一次真正看到该趋势指标有所增加。所以这对我们来说也非常令人震惊。你知道，我们已经说了一段时间了，每10个少女中至少有1个被强奸过。在我们观察这些十年趋势的这些年里，这一数据一直很稳定。
And that changed. So, yes, we were very alarmed. We look to our programmatic work to see how we can help. And we do have school-based strategies that address some of these issues, which I know we'll talk about today. So I think, you know, you see the data. It is extremely alarming. It is our public health duty to get the data out and talked about and make it made accessible, which, you know, we've been trying to do. The next question, as you mentioned, is what do we, why?
但情况发生了变化。所以，是的，我们非常震惊。我们审视我们的项目工作，看看如何提供帮助。我们确实有针对其中一些问题的校本策略，我知道我们今天会谈到。所以我认为，你知道，你看到了这些数据。这极其令人震惊。将这些数据公布出来、进行讨论并使其易于获取是我们的公共卫生职责，这也是我们一直努力在做的。正如你提到的，下一个问题是：为什么？
Why is this? Why are we seeing this data? And then the next question after that is what do we do about it? With girls in particular and just the fact that these numbers are so alarming, do you have any way of knowing what? whether this is just a question of they're more willing to tell the truth on polls than they had been in prior years. Might that be a factor that there's more openness about this kind of conversation now? I think that I think it's very likely that we are doing a better job giving young people the language to describe their mental health. I don't know that it's less about telling the truth.
为什么会这样？为什么我们会看到这些数据？接下来的问题是：我们该怎么办？特别是考虑到女孩的情况以及这些数字如此令人震惊的事实，您是否有办法知道这是否仅仅是因为她们比往年更愿意在民意调查中说真话？现在对这类话题的开放程度更高，这可能是一个因素吗？我认为很有可能我们做得更好的一点是，赋予了年轻人描述其心理健康的语言。我不确定这是否与“说真话”的程度有关。
This is an anonymous survey and it's always been an anonymous survey. So I think, you know, perhaps there is less stigma, you know, about talking about mental health. But I also do think that we in a really positive way are, have been giving young people the language to say what's happening with them. What concerns me is that while we're giving them the language to talk to describe their mental health on an understanding. anonymous survey, what I worry about is that we aren't giving them the pathways to tell adults, whether that's their parents or their school counselors or their teachers or a mental health professional, you know, or their primary care doctor. That we're not given, that we, I'm, not sure that data doesn't tell us that we've given them the pathway to, to get help. And that
这是一项匿名调查，而且一直都是匿名调查。所以我认为，也许谈论心理健康带来的污名化减少了。但我确实认为，我们以一种非常积极的方式，一直在赋予年轻人描述自身状况的语言。我担心的是，虽然我们赋予了他们在匿名调查中描述心理健康的语言，但我担心的是，我们没有为他们提供告诉成年人的途径，无论是他们的父母、学校辅导员、老师、心理健康专业人士，还是他们的初级保健医生。我不确定数据是否表明我们已经为他们提供了寻求帮助的途径。而这
worries me. Before we get too much further into this, I wanted to ask you about the cohort, the data, how you do this, how many kids are involved, how is it nationally representative? How do you pull it all together and how are these youth basically approached and polled? So this is a school-based survey, so this is a survey of 9th through 12 graders. And this year, the sample size was over. Over 17,000 young people collected in schools across the country. Again, we've been doing this survey for more than 30 years. It is part of a system of surveys. So the data that I'm talking with you about that we released in this report is part of a national survey.
让我感到担忧。在我们深入探讨之前，我想问一下关于队列、数据、你们如何进行这项调查、有多少孩子参与、它在全国范围内是否具有代表性？你们是如何汇总这些数据的，以及这些青少年是如何被接触和调查的？这是一项校本调查，所以这是针对9到12年级学生的调查。今年，样本量超过了17,000名在全国学校收集的年轻人。同样，我们进行这项调查已经超过30年了。它是调查系统的一部分。所以我和你谈论的我们在本报告中发布的数据是全国性调查的一部分。
There are also 47 state surveys and 28 local surveys. So there are across the country, there are lots of individual youth risk behavior surveys that are conducted. And so we can, we collect this data in conjunction with the states and locals as well. So we, we work with them so that we're, you know, we're not overtaxing any individual school because they appear in either the national or the state sample. We, we use a sampling frame and it's probably somewhat complicated, but we use a sampling frame that allows us to use the demographics of the school, of the individual school to make sure that the data is nationally representative. It doesn't mean that data from every, it doesn't include data from every state,
还有47项州级调查和28项地方调查。因此，全国各地进行了许多单独的青少年风险行为调查。我们与各州和地方合作收集这些数据。我们与他们合作，这样我们就不会给任何特定的学校增加负担，因为他们出现在全国或州样本中。我们使用抽样框架，这可能有点复杂，但我们使用的抽样框架允许我们利用学校的人口统计数据，以确保数据在全国范围内具有代表性。这并不意味着数据来自每个州，
but it is nationally representative. And we do a lot of, we do a lot of like non-biased testing to make sure that if, you know, we get data from a school. And then we have a different school that says, no, we really don't want you to come in, that there isn't kind of systematic differences between schools that agree to participate in schools that don't. So there's a lot of methodological and analytic support that we use in the sample to make sure that it is nationally representative. For all the data geeks who listen to your podcast. And I'm sure there are some. So I have to ask you about social media because there's been so much public and media attention recently to how social media can harm teens' mental health.
但它在全国范围内具有代表性。我们做了很多无偏见测试，以确保如果我们从一所学校获得数据，而另一所学校说“不，我们真的不想让你进来”，那么同意参与的学校和不同意的学校之间不会存在系统性差异。因此，我们在样本中使用了大量的分析支持，以确保其在全国范围内具有代表性。对于所有收听您播客的数据极客来说，我相信肯定有一些。所以我必须问你关于社交媒体的问题，因为最近公众和媒体对社交媒体如何损害青少年心理健康给予了极大的关注。
Do you think at least some of the blame for what we're seeing in this survey lies there? You know, I think it's, I think it is more complicated than it would, honestly, it would be wonderful to have kind of a silver bullet that if we just fix that one thing, then this would all get better. I don't think that that's the case, although I think that social media does come with significant risks and the potential for significant harm. But it also comes with a lot of opportunity for connection. And it comes with a lot of opportunity for young people to access information that they may not have any other way of accessing. And so it's not the kind of thing that I think we want to kind of throw it. out without really kind of trying to figure out what should we keep what's important for young people to have and and then what should we how should we try to protect them I think and this is
你认为我们在这次调查中看到的情况，至少有一部分责任在于此吗？你知道，我认为这比这更复杂。老实说，如果能有一个“灵丹妙药”，只要我们解决了那件事，一切都会好起来，那将是美妙的。我不认为情况是这样，尽管我认为社交媒体确实伴随着巨大的风险和造成重大伤害的潜力。但它也带来了很多建立联系的机会。它也为年轻人提供了获取他们可能无法通过其他方式获取的信息的机会。所以我不认为我们应该在没有真正弄清楚我们应该保留什么、什么对年轻人重要，以及我们应该如何保护他们的情况下，就把它扔掉。我认为，这就是
where social media probably plays in I think a lot of what's underlying this is social isolation you know we as humans and I think you know the folks listening to your podcast who are who are their psychologists themselves are interested in psychology. I think we know, and as a social psychologist myself, we know that as humans, we are social beings. We require social interaction. And many of the things that we're looking at in this report, both in terms of, I think, substance use and experience of violence and mental health and suicidality, have some component of social isolation as a cause underneath. And so I think with, and I think that's, you know, partially why the pandemic was so impactful was because we were separated from each other. And young
社交媒体可能发挥作用的地方。我认为这背后的很多原因是社会孤立。你知道，作为人类，我想收听你播客的人如果本身就是心理学家或对心理学感兴趣，我们都知道，作为社会心理学家，我们知道作为人类，我们是社会性动物。我们需要社会互动。我们在本报告中观察到的许多事情，无论是物质使用、暴力经历还是心理健康和自杀倾向，在某种程度上都以社会孤立为诱因。所以我认为，这就是为什么疫情影响如此之大的部分原因，因为我们彼此分离了。年轻人
people lost the supports that they have in school. They lost their peer groups for periods of time. And I think that was really impactful. And I think we on the opposite side see the power of connectedness in protecting the health and well-being of young people. And so, So where social media comes in, I think, is that that can become a substitute connector. And so can provide some connection. What I'm not sure about is whether it provides real connection in a way that protects health and well-being. And if not, how do we shift young people to connections that are more fulfilling? and support them in ways that the connection that they're getting through social media probably
失去了他们在学校的支持。他们在一段时间内失去了同伴群体。我认为这影响很大。而在另一方面，我们看到了联结的力量在保护年轻人健康和福祉方面的作用。所以，社交媒体发挥作用的地方在于，它可能成为一种替代性的连接方式。因此可以提供一些连接。我不确定的是，它是否以一种保护健康和福祉的方式提供了真正的连接。如果不是，我们如何引导年轻人建立更充实的连接？并以社交媒体可能无法提供的方式支持他们。
doesn't. Yeah. Some of the really shocking numbers that came out of this report were for girls and LGBTQ plus teens. And I say LGBTQ without the T because I know you didn't ask about gender identity this time. Right. Why do you think these two groups were faring so much worse than boys or at least than straight boys? and how were boys doing? So, I mean, in many ways, no, especially around mental health and suicide, we saw increases
是的。这份报告中出现的一些非常令人震惊的数字是关于女孩和LGBTQ+青少年的。我省略了T，因为我知道你这次没有询问性别认同。对吧。你认为为什么这两个群体的情况比男孩，或者至少比异性恋男孩糟糕得多？男孩们的情况如何？所以，我的意思是，在许多方面，不，特别是在心理健康和自杀方面，我们看到了
across every, across both boys and girls across every racial and ethnic group that we included. And in this report, we actually included seven categories of race ethnicity, which we hadn't done before. And I think neither LGBTQ plus youth or straight youth were doing particularly well. mental health. I mean, 40% overall, 40% of the students in the sample said that they felt so persistently sad and hopeless for at least two weeks in the last year that they couldn't do the regular activities, which, you know, you will all recognize as depressive symptoms. And so,
男孩和女孩在每个种族和族裔群体中都有所增加。在本报告中，我们实际上包含了七个种族/族裔类别，这是我们以前没有做过的。我认为无论是LGBTQ+青少年还是异性恋青少年，心理健康状况都不是特别好。我的意思是，样本中40%的学生表示，他们在过去一年中至少有两周感到持续的悲伤和绝望，以至于无法进行正常的活动，你们都会认出这是抑郁症状。所以，
you know, that I just, I do want to say that, you know, it's not like, you know, girls were doing terrible and boys were doing so much better. I mean, girls were doing significantly worse than boys and LGBTQ LGBTQ LGBTQ plus students were doing significantly worse than than heterosexual youth most of the almost consistently in the same way that we saw in this report for girls LGBTQ plus youth had already been significantly doing significantly worse than straight youth prior to the pandemic so we had really consistently been seeing that data since 2015, which is when we started asking about sexual identity. So, and we don't have trends on this population for this year because we changed the question
你知道，我只是想说，并不是说女孩表现得很糟糕，而男孩表现得好得多。我的意思是，女孩的表现明显比男孩差，LGBTQ+学生的表现明显比异性恋青少年差。几乎在报告中看到的女孩的情况一样，LGBTQ+青少年在疫情之前就已经明显比异性恋青少年差了。所以自2015年我们开始询问性取向以来，我们一直持续地看到这些数据。所以，我们今年没有这个人群的趋势数据，因为我们更改了问题，
to be better reflective of sexual identity. And so we were, we were less surprised because we had been seeing it, but nowhere less concerned that a quarter, for instance, a quarter of LGBTQ plus students attempted suicide in the year prior to the survey. That's really high, you know, to think about a quarter of those students didn't, you know, attempted to not be here anymore. Like that just, you know, that is just really devastating. I think as much as we've made significant strides in positive support for LGBTQ plus students, there's still a long way to go. And I think, you know, the conversations, the public conversations over the last few years
以便更好地反映性取向。所以我们并没有那么惊讶，但我们依然非常担心，例如，四分之一的LGBTQ+学生在调查前一年尝试过自杀。这真的很高，你知道，想到四分之一的学生尝试过不再留在这个世界上。这真的非常令人痛心。我认为尽管我们在为LGBTQ+学生提供积极支持方面取得了重大进展，但仍有很长的路要走。我认为，过去几年里的对话，
around, certainly around trans youth, which again, we haven't, we didn't include that question in this sample. But it affects, it affects, you know, all young people in that way. And so I think we would be naive to think that those conversations are not impacting them. I mean, we do have, you know, earlier studies that have shown that in states prior to marriage equality becoming available across the country, when we looked at states that supported marriage equality versus those that did not, we saw significant differences in suicidal thoughts and behaviors in LGBTQ plus students. And so we know that the social environment, when it is
当然是围绕跨性别青少年的，我们在这个样本中没有包含这个问题。但这确实以这种方式影响了所有年轻人。所以我认为如果我们认为这些对话没有影响他们，那就太天真了。我的意思是，我们确实有早期的研究表明，在全国范围内实现婚姻平权之前，当我们观察支持婚姻平权的州与不支持的州时，我们看到LGBTQ+学生的自杀念头和行为存在显著差异。所以我们知道，当社会环境支持时，它会对那些年轻人产生积极影响。所以，这些数据并没有告诉我们，但如果你问我，你认为当前的对话有什么影响？暗示它们没有负面影响是不可能的。当然。你可能也无法从数据中看出这一点。但作为一个社会，当许多政客和其他人使教育工作者和其他人无法在学校公开谈论LGBTQ问题时，我们如何才能为这一特定群体提供帮助？你知道，从联邦的角度来看，倡导或反对任何特定的州法律或政策当然不是我的职责。那不是我的角色。
supportive, has a positive impact on those young people. So I'm, this data doesn't tell us, But if you're asking me to, you know, what impact do I think the current conversations are having? It's impossible to suggest that they're not having a negative impact. Sure. And you probably can't tell this from the data either. But how can we as a society get help to this particular group of teens when so many politicians and others are making it impossible for educators and other people to speak openly about LGBTQ issues in schools? You know, it's certainly not my role from the federal perspective to, you know, advocate for or against any particular state law or policy. That's not my role.
但我们的研究表明，当你让学校对LGBTQ+学生不那么具有敌意时。当你在学校实施支持这些年轻人的政策和实践时，不仅那些认同为女同性恋、男同性恋、双性恋或表示自己处于探索阶段的年轻人在心理健康和自杀念头及行为方面表现更好，而且在同一所学校中认同为异性恋的青少年，他们的心理健康状况也更好，自杀念头和行为也更少。所以我们看到的是，当你让学校对最脆弱的青少年减少敌意时，你就让学校对每个人都变得更友好、更具支持性。
But our research has shown that when you make schools, for instance, less toxic for LGBTQ plus students. So when you put policies and practices in place in schools to support those young. people, not only do young people who identify as lesbian, gay, bisexual, or say that they're questioning do better in terms of their mental health and their, and suicidal thoughts and behavior, but straight youth in those schools, the youth who identify as heterosexual in those same schools also have better mental health and less suicidal thoughts and behaviors. And so what we see is that when you make schools less toxic for the most vulnerable youth, you make schools less toxic and more supportive for everyone.
所以，你知道，当然，当你有一群年轻人的表现明显比其他人差时，你会想要谈论所有可以支持他们的方式，以及你可以尝试扭转局面的方式。但有趣的是，支持这些年轻人也帮助了所有人。在我们数据中看到的这种没有人表现特别好的环境中，让如此重要的环境对任何群体变得更具敌意，
And so, you know, I, you know, of course, when you have a group of young people who are fearing significantly worse than others, you want to, you know, you want to talk about all the ways in which they can be supported and you can, you know, in the ways in which you can try to turn that around. But interestingly, supporting them. those young people also helps everybody. And in an environment that we're seeing in our data where no one's doing particularly well to make such important environments more toxic for any group of young people,
理解它如何影响每个人，我认为这让我感到担忧。现在，我想强调的是，最近关于青少年风险行为的报告并非全是坏消息，对吧？我的意思是，在某些领域，青少年的表现比之前的调查要好。你能谈谈这些领域以及这些改善的一些可能原因吗？是的。所以，当我们观察这十年趋势时，在过去三波数据中，我们一直看到性行为朝着正确的方向发展。有趣的是，你知道，从2007年到2017年，然后是2009年到2019年，现在我们观察的是2011年到2021年。在那段时间的开始，即2011年，不同种族/族裔在曾经发生过性行为、有多个性伴侣、目前有性生活的青少年比例上存在显著差异。不仅每个人都有所改善，而且这些差异、这些差距已经缩小了。现在，这些群体之间不再像我们过去看到的那样存在显著差异。我们不知道这具体为什么会发生。我想我们花了很多时间教育年轻人关于我们认为对他们健康的积极行为。所以他们听进去了。我们在物质使用方面也看到了同样的情况。
understanding the way that it affects everyone, I think, worries me. Now, I want to stress that the recent report on youth risk behavior was not all bad news, right? I mean, there were some areas where youth did better than on prior service. Can you talk about those and some of the possible reasons for those improvements? Yeah. So we have, we've been consistently over, you know, the last three waves of this data when we looked at these 10-year trends. We've been seeing sexual behaviors move in the right direction for a while. And interestingly, you know, starting so, you know, we looked at 2007 to 2017 and then then 2,000 and then 2,000 and.
所以，尽管我们看到女孩和男孩之间存在这种差异，但总的来说，在我们报告中包含的所有指标中，物质使用一直在下降。同样，它们并非YRBS中包含的所有指标，但在我们观察了一段时间的这组指标中，它们都朝着正确的方向发展。所以我认为这些是积极的事情，因为当你给年轻人提供关于他们健康的信息和做出这些改变的技能时，他们是能够做到的。我们看到的非积极的领域是发生在他们身上的事情，比如暴力经历，以及这些经历带来的心理健康影响。
9 to 2019, and now we're looking at 2011 to 2021. At the beginning of that time period, that 2011 time period, there were significant differences by race ethnicity in the proportion of youth who had ever had sex, who had multiple sex partners who were currently sexually active. Not only has everybody improved, but those differences, those disparities have closed. And now there aren't significant differences between those groups and the way that. that we used to see. We don't know exactly why that's occurring. I think we've spent a lot of time kind of, you know, educating young people about the positive behaviors that we think will be healthy for them. And so they listen. And we've been seeing the same thing across substance use as well.
现在，您在CDC的部门致力于为学校提供资源，以帮助解决暴力和心理健康问题。您能告诉我们更多关于学校如何帮助青少年，以及CDC在这个领域具体在做什么吗？当然。关于学校的具体情况。再次说明，我的部门是青少年与学校健康部门。我们有一个名为“学校行之有效”（What Works in Schools）的项目。该项目致力于改善健康教育，确保学校落实高质量的健康教育计划。它致力于帮助学校里的年轻人与所需的健康服务建立联系。然后，它进行了一系列我们称之为“安全与支持性环境”的工作。
So even though we see this disparity between girls and boys, in general, substance use has been going down across all of the measures that we included in this report. And again, they're not all the measures, you know, contained in Y or BS, but across this set that we've been looking at for a while, they've all moved in the right direction. So I think that those are positive things in the sense that when you give young people information about their health and skills to make those changes, they are able to do that. What the areas that we're seeing that are, not positive, are the things that are happening to them, like the experience of violence, and then the resulting mental health impact of those experiences.
这包括从确保教师拥有管理他们在课堂上看到的心理和行为健康问题所需的培训和技能——他们一直告诉我们，特别是在疫情之后，他们正在处理这些问题——到确保落实青少年发展项目，这些项目在帮助年轻人感到参与并与学校里的重要他人和重要成年人建立联系方面非常有效。然后就是我刚才谈到的关于确保学校落实支持LGBTQ青少年的政策和实践。当学校完成所有这些工作时，我们看到，在同一个学区，如果你观察实施这些项目的学校与没有实施的学校，即使在同一个学区，实施该项目的学校，我们看到性行为减少，物质使用减少。我们看到强迫性行为和因担心安全而没去上学的青少年比例都有所下降。所以它改善了
Now, your division at the CDC works on resources for schools to help address violence and mental health. Can you tell us more about how schools can help teens and what exactly it is that the CDC is doing in this area? Sure. So specifically about schools. So again, my division's the division of adolescent in school health. We have a program called What Works in Schools. And what that program does is it works to improve health education, so making sure that schools are putting in place quality health education programs. It works to help connect young people in their schools to needed health services. And then it does a collection of what we call safe and supportive environment work.
学校环境的安全性。特别是在落实了LGBTQ包容性政策和实践的学校，我们确实看到了对心理健康的积极影响，以及LGBTQ青少年和异性恋青少年自杀倾向的降低。CDC是否向美国的所有学校，所有公立学校，公立和私立学校提供这些政策和实践？我的意思是，任何学校都可以吗？如果家长说我孩子去的学校没有这样做，他们该如何推动实施？
And that is everything from, making sure teachers have the training and the skills that they need to help manage the mental and behavioral health issues that they're seeing in their classrooms, they're telling us all the time that they're dealing with, especially since the pandemic, making sure that their youth development programs in place, which are really effective in helping young people feel engaged and connected to important others in their schools and to important adults. And then this set of things that, you know, I was just talking about in terms of making sure that schools are put in place policies and practices to support LGBTQ youth. When schools do all of that work, what we see is that in the same district, if you look at schools that put those programs in place versus schools that don't, even in the same district, that the schools that put the program in place, we see decreases in sexual behavior, we see decreases in substance use. We see decreases in both forced sex and in the proportion of young people who say they didn't go to school because they were worried about their safety. So it improves
当然。我们目前资助了28个大型城市学区来实施“学校行之有效”项目。我们非常高兴“学校行之有效”被纳入了白宫昨天发布的预算简报中以进行扩展。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。它是行为健康转型倡议的一部分，我们对此感到非常激动。但我们把所有与学校合作的方式，即我们建议学校做的所有事情，
kind of the safety of the school environment. And particularly in the schools that put the LGBTQ inclusivity policies and practices in place, that's really where we see the positive impact on mental health and decreases in suicidality for both LGBT. LGBTQ youth and heterosexual youth. And the CDC makes these policies and practices available to what all schools in America, all public schools, public and private. I mean, can any school, and if a parent says where my kid goes, the school isn't doing it, how can they get it implemented?
都放在了我们的网站上。“学校行之有效”项目在我们的网站上有描述。我们将我们的项目指南提供给任何想要使用它的人。所以这为你提供了我们建议你做的所有事情的详细步骤。所以，你知道，我们正在努力扩大规模，因为它在解决我们在数据中看到的我们所担心的某些问题方面非常有效。我们对能够扩展该项目的前景感到非常兴奋。现在，培训青少年互相帮助怎么样？你知道，有很多关于同伴干预的报道，
Sure. So we currently fund 28 large urban school districts to put the What Works and Schools program in place. we are very excited that what works in schools was included in the budget and brief that was released by the White House yesterday for expansion. So we're really excited about that. It's part of the behavioral health transformation initiative and we're just thrilled about that. But we put the all of the ways in which we work with school. So all of the things that we recommend that schools do,
这可以帮助青少年识别同伴中抑郁或自杀的迹象。我只是想知道在你们所做的工作中，是否有这类项目的空间。是的，我的意思是，我真的认为这是一种很好的技术。你知道，CDC的暴力预防部门有一些非常棒的旁观者干预项目，他们一直在为学校进行研究，我认为这可以帮助支持学校环境的安全性和支持性。我认为这些是非常好的方法。我们非常致力于如何让年轻人更多地参与到他们的学校中。所以我们目前有一个关于如何帮助学校建立青少年咨询委员会的项目。所以，我认为
are available on our website. The What Works and Schools program is described on our website. We make our program guidance available to anybody who would like to use it. So that kind of gives you the play by play of all the things that we recommend that you do. And so, you know, we're working on scaling it up because it is so effective in addressing some of the exact things that we're concerned about in the data that we see. And we're really excited about the possibility of being able to expand the program. Now, what about training teens to help each other? You know, there's been a lot of reporting on peer-to-peer interventions
无论是在个人层面帮助年轻人识别同伴身上发生的事情并支持他们，并帮助提供通往重要支持的途径，还是让青少年参与进来，听取他们对学校的需求，都是非常重要的方法。就在上周，我们听取了一些来自不同州的年轻人的演讲，他们实际上是他们州教育委员会的成员。我只是觉得那是最棒的方法。这些年轻人令人难以置信。他们非常聪明，能够谈论他们的学校需要什么。所以我当时在想，对于州教育委员会的成年人来说，他们一定是多么宝贵的资源。我希望更多的州决定做那种
that could help teens recognize the signs of depression or suicide in their fellow teens. And I'm just wondering if there's a place in what you're doing for these kinds of programs. Yeah, I mean, I really think that that's a great technique. You know, the Division of Violence Prevention at CDC has some really wonderful bystander. intervention programs that they've been working on for schools that I think can help support the safety and supportiveness of school environments. I think those are really great kinds of approaches. We are very much working on how to engage young people more in their schools. So we currently have a project about how to help schools set up youth advisory boards. And I think, so I think both
工作，但让年轻人参与开发解决我们在他们中间看到的问题的方案，对吧？他们告诉我们他们处于危机之中。我们应该问问他们需要什么。那么，对于担心孩子目前状况的青少年家长，他们在家里能做些什么来识别麻烦的迹象并获得支持？CDC是否有家长可以使用的资源？所以有几件事。我们在一些育儿方法上有很多资源，比如家长监督，这实际上是一个花哨的名称，意思是知道你的孩子在哪里，
on the individual level in terms of helping young people recognize what's going on with their peers and supporting them and helping provide that pathway to important support, as well as engaging youth in hearing from them what they need in their schools are all really important approaches. We just last week had some presentations from young people from a couple of different states who are actually on their state boards of education. And I just thought that was the most wonderful approach. And these young people were incredible. They were so smart and so able to talk about what their schools needed. And so I was imagining what a great resource that they must be for the adults who are on their state boards of education. And I hope that more states decide to do that kind of
和谁在一起，在做什么。我们知道这对年轻人非常有保护作用。我认为我们对家长监督的了解是，它需要家长真正参与进来，对吧？除非他们提出问题，除非年轻人告诉他们，否则他们不会知道他们的青少年在哪里，在做什么，和谁在一起。这需要一种给予和索取、信任和建立关系的过程。另一件事，你知道，当我们谈论这些数据时，我认为家长可以做的一件事，而且这要从早期开始，对吧？这不是
work, but engaging young people in developing the solutions for the problems that we're seeing among them, right? Like, they're telling us they're in crisis. We should be asking them what they need. So for parents of teens who are concerned about what's happening with their kids right now, what can they do at home to recognize the signs of trouble and get support? And does the CDC have resources that parents could use? So a couple things. We have a lot of resources on some parenting approaches like parental monitoring, which is really a fancy name for know where your kids are,
等到你的孩子成为青少年才开始这种对话。但我认为家长可以从幼儿时期就开始谈论“你感觉如何？”并赋予他们语言：我感到快乐。我感到悲伤。我感到愤怒。我感到沮丧。然后参与其中，好吧，那么我们该怎么办？你知道，我们如何处理快乐？当你感到悲伤时我们该怎么办？并将这种对话正常化，这样你就不会等到青少年时期才去想如何与你的青少年谈论他们的心理健康。所以我强烈建议幼儿家长尽早开始这些对话。
who they're with and what they're doing. And we know that that is really protective for young people. And I think what we also know about parental monitoring is that it involves parents really being engaged, right? They don't, they're not going to know where their teams are and what they're doing and who they're with unless they are asking the questions and unless their young people are telling them. And that and that requires that there be this kind of give and take and trust and relationship building. The other thing, you know, we've been, as we've been talking a lot about this data, I think one thing for that parents can do, and this starts early, right? This is not
我认为我们从我们所了解的社会和情感学习中知道，教导孩子如何管理他们的情绪，如何通过它们进行协商，如何理解它们是什么并处理这些情绪是非常重要的，并且可以产生非常长期的影响。对于青少年家长，我可以肯定地说，你可以确保你关注行为的变化、食欲的变化、睡眠模式的变化，任何在你的青少年表现方面看起来不同的事情。如果你还没有开始这些对话，那就开始吧。我认为在各种网站上都有很好的资源。
about waiting until your child is a teenager and starting this conversation. But I think parents can be starting with their young children to talk about how are you feeling? And giving them language, I feel happy. I feel sad. I feel angry. I feel frustrated. And to then engage with, okay, well, so what should we do about that? How, you know, what do we do with the happiness? What do we do when you feel sad? And, and, and, and, normalizing that conversation, that conversation so that you don't get to the teenage years and need to be trying to figure out how to talk to your teenager about their mental health. So I would really strongly encourage parents of young children to start those conversations early.
我会尝试找出你所在社区的服务在哪里。我知道这对家长来说现在是一个巨大的问题，即在需要时找到服务。所以只要知道这一点。与你的初级保健医生交谈。你知道，希望他们能有一些方法让你与当地的服务资源建立联系。所以，你知道，有一整套你可以做的事情。我会说，我们的研究表明，回到联结性，家庭联结性，那种纽带感、信任感、亲密感，家庭联结性对健康和福祉有长期的影响，不仅是在青春期，而且一直持续到
I think that we know from kind of what we know about social and emotional learning, teaching children how to manage their emotions, how to negotiate through them, how to, you know, kind of understand what they are and work with those emotions is really important and can have, you know, really long-term impact. I will say for parents of teenagers, you can make sure that you're attending to changes in behavior, changes in appetite, changes in sleep patterns, anything that looks different in terms of the way that your teenager is acting. And to start those conversations if you haven't, if you haven't already, I think there are great resources across a whole variety of websites.
成年。所以，就像我们看到学校联结性对各种结果有20年的影响一样，家庭联结性也有。所以，7到12年级的年轻人说他们感到与家人亲近和联结的程度，20年后，他们的心理健康状况更好，自杀的可能性更小，他们的身体状况更好，使用物质的可能性更小，所有这些事情。我们在学校联结性方面也看到了类似的情况。我们在创造安全和支持性学校环境方面所做的大部分工作都是为了增加学校联结性。家庭联结性同样重要。所以，你知道，对于青少年家长来说，这似乎
and I would, you know, try to find out where services are in your, in your community. I know that's a huge problem for parents right now is finding services when they need them. So just kind of know that. Talk to your primary care provider. You know, hopefully they will have some ways for you to connect with local sources of services. So, you know, there's a whole kind of, there's a whole array of things you can do. I will say that our research shows that connect back to connectedness, that family connectedness, so that sense of bond, that sense of trust, that sense of closeness, family connectedness, has long-term implications for health and well-being, not just during adolescence, but well into
我会建议你试着去了解你所在社区的服务资源。我知道目前对家长来说，在需要时找到这些服务是一个巨大的难题。所以，请务必了解这一点。与你的初级保健医生沟通，希望他们能为你提供一些联系当地服务资源的途径。总之，你可以做的事情有很多。我想说的是，我们的研究表明，回归到“联结感”这一核心，即家庭联结感——那种纽带感、信任感和亲密感——不仅在青春期，而且在成年后，都对健康和幸福有着长期的影响。
adulthood. And so in the same way that we see that school connectedness has 20-year impacts on a whole wide variety of outcomes, family connectedness does as well. So the degree to which young people in 7 through 12th grade said that they felt close to and connected to their family, 20 years later, they have better mental health, they are less likely to be suicidal, they have better, they have better physical, they're less likely to use substances, all of those things. We see that similarly with school connectedness. And a lot of what we do in terms of creating safe and supportive school environments is meant to increase school connectedness. Family connectedness is just as important. So, you know, it may seem, it may seem for parents of teenagers
同样，正如我们所见，学校联结感对各种结果有着长达20年的影响，家庭联结感也是如此。七到十二年级的年轻人如果表示他们与家人关系亲密、联系紧密，那么20年后，他们的心理健康状况更好，自杀倾向更低，身体状况更好，滥用药物的可能性也更小，所有这些方面都是如此。我们在学校联结感方面也看到了类似的情况。我们在营造安全和支持性的学校环境方面所做的大量工作，目的就是为了增强学校联结感。家庭联结感同样重要。所以，对于青少年家长来说，这看起来可能
that it's hard to make that connection, but they do want it. It may seem like they're pushing you away, but they do want to be connected to you. And those connections have, long-term impact. So keep trying. Keep trying. Just keep it up. Keep trying. It's easy for me to say. I don't have kids. So last question. What's next for your division's research and when will the results of the next youth risk behavior survey be available? So this is actually, this report is one teeny, tiny little piece of all of the data that we have available. And so, you know, we wanted, because, Because I think of the importance of it, we wanted to get it out as quickly as we could. And we wanted it to be accessible.
建立这种联系很难，但他们确实渴望这种联系。他们看起来可能是在把你推开，但他们确实希望与你保持联系。这些联系具有长期的影响。所以要坚持尝试。坚持尝试。继续努力。坚持尝试。我说起来容易，因为我没有孩子。那么最后一个问题。你们部门的研究接下来有什么计划？下一次青少年风险行为调查的结果什么时候公布？实际上，这份报告只是我们所有可用数据中极小的一部分。因为我认为它很重要，所以我们希望尽快将其发布出来。我们希望它能易于获取。
And we wanted it to be, while scientifically sound, we wanted people to be able to look at it and read it and take it in. I think that's happened. So we're really excited about that. But then we release, there will be a set of morbidity and mortality weekly reports that will come out at the end of April that will detail other areas. Some of the same outcomes will be included in some of the reports. But I think there's nine papers. There will be a big overview paper if you're interested in the methodology of the YRBS, as well as kind of additional individual papers that look more at the interrelationships
我们希望它在科学上是严谨的，同时也希望人们能够阅读并理解它。我认为这一点已经做到了。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。接下来，我们将发布一系列《发病率和死亡率周报》，这些报告将于四月底发布，并将详细介绍其他领域。其中一些报告会包含相同的结果。但我认为总共有九篇论文。如果你对青少年风险行为调查（YRBS）的方法论感兴趣，将会有一篇大型综述论文，以及一些深入探讨变量之间相互关系的独立论文。
between some of these variables. And then right around that time, we will release all of the data. So both the national data and all of the state and local data will be available on youth online. That is the way that we make that data available. And so that will just open it up for anybody who's really interested in digging further into the data, we'll be able to do that. We have a number of papers that are in the works from this data. And I encourage anyone who really wants to dig in and look and do their own analyses. We have the way to provide public use data sets to folks who want them.
在这些变量之间。大约在那个时候，我们将发布所有数据。届时，全国数据以及所有州和地方的数据都将在“青少年在线”（Youth Online）平台上发布。这就是我们提供数据的方式。这将向任何真正有兴趣深入挖掘数据的人开放，他们将能够做到这一点。我们有许多基于这些数据正在撰写中的论文。我鼓励任何真正想深入研究并进行自己分析的人。我们有办法为想要数据的人提供公共使用数据集。
and we'll be happy to do that. There's a link to that you can request those data sets. So for, again, all of your data-oriented listeners, they're there. And then we'll collect the 2020-3 survey is currently in the field. So that will be available probably in about a year and a half. Okay. All right. Well, that's very interesting.
我们很乐意这样做。有一个链接可以让你申请这些数据集。所以，再次提醒所有喜欢数据的朋友，数据就在那里。此外，我们正在进行2023年的调查。所以这些数据可能在大约一年半后可用。好的。好的，这非常有趣。
Thanks. We'll try to put some links in our show notes, especially we have a lot of students who listen and they may be interested in digging into the numbers. So I want to thank you for joining. us, Dr. Ether, this has been really interesting. Thanks so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. Also, another reminder we'd like to hear from you about what you think of this podcast
谢谢。我们会尽量在节目笔记中放入一些链接，特别是考虑到我们有很多学生听众，他们可能对挖掘这些数字感兴趣。所以我想感谢你加入我们，Ether博士，这真的非常有趣。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或任何你收听播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。另外，再次提醒，我们想听听你对这个播客的看法。
and what are the topics you'd like us to explore. So please go to speakingof psychology.org and look for the link to our listener's survey. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及你希望我们探讨哪些话题。所以请访问speakingofpsychology.org并查找听众调查的链接。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的音效编辑是Chris Condayan。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。